un petit pavillon tranquille qui ne
laisse rien deviner du drame qui s'est
produit dimanche matin c'est la soeur de
la défunte qui alertent les gendarmes
les secours découvrent alors deux corps
sans vie
jacques et marie jo qui gisent dans leur
chambre tuées par balles les premiers
éléments indiquent qu'il pourrait s'agir
d'un geste désespéré il était très
gentil très discret on n'entendait
jamais parler d'eux la dame elle
s'occupait de la bibliothèque dans le
village les enfants l'aiment et bien une
famille frappée par plusieurs drames
successifs en 2011 la fille du couple se
donne la mort en se jetant d'une falaise
en voiture avec ses deux enfants un
petit garçon de 3 ans et une petite
fille de trois mois en février dernier
c'est leur fils qui choisit d'en finir
alors dans ce village où tout le monde
se connaît personne n'est vraiment
surpris de ce qui est arrivé
on est tous très choqués pas étonné mais
très très choquée quoi qu'ils aient pu
en venir à ce stade mais pas étonnée
parce que vu tout ce qu'ils ont subi
on peut comprendre mais en même temps et
c'est quelqu'un il disait jamais
extérieurs mais tant entendu parler de
sa fille quand il parle de sa fille on
sentait qu'il était pas de la
gendarmerie de côte-d'or a été saisie et
le parquet de dijon a ouvert une enquête
jacques et marie jo champ blanc était
âgé de 72 ans